ALL RIGHT GOOD MORNING I LIKE TO
CALL THIS OUR TO IN
ENTERTAINMENT COMMITTEE TO ORDER
WE DON'T HAVE A QUORUM YET.
BUT WE DO HOUSE HAVE SENATORS%
STORM HERE 2%. EIGHTY SB SEVEN
FORTY EIGHT SO LIKE TO CALL THE
SUBCOMMITTEE. TO PUT IN ORDER
[inaudible]
SENATOR.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR.
THANK YOU MEMBERS FOR BEING HERE
THIS MORNING.
THIS BILL IS ABOUT VOICE FOR A
NEW GENERATION [inaudible]
THAT.
IT'S TOO OFTEN VOICELESS NOT
JUST IN THIS CAPITAL BUT IN THIS
COUNTRY.
AND WE FEEL THAT ART IS A WAY
FOR YOUNG PEOPLE TO SPEAK.
GWENDOLYN BROOKS SAID I SHALL
CREATE.
IF NOT A NOTE THE WHOLE.
IF NOT AN OVERTURE THE
DESECRATION.
YOUNG PEOPLE WILL CREATE.
THE QUESTION IS WHAT TOOLS DO WE
GIVE THEM.
I THINK THIS BILL GIVES THEM
TOOLS BY ESTABLISHING YOUTH POET
LAUREATE.
IN THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA THAT
HAS PARITY WITH OUR CURRENT POET
LAUREATE. TO PUT ON ON PAR.
IT'S A MATTER OF ART.
AS A MATTER OF CONSCIENCE -- THE
NEXT GENERATIONS VOICE SO WITH
THAT I RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR AYE
VOTE NO ONE INTRODUCE ARE
EXCELLENT WITNESSES FROM THE
CALIFORNIA ARTS COMMISSION --
ARTS COUNCIL -- BEEN DOING
INCREDIBLE WORK THESE PAST FEW
YEARS TO THE STABILIZE
INVESTMENT IN THIS SORT OF ROOTS
OF THE CREATIVE ECONOMY WHERE WE
CAN GROW TALENT -- EDITS
YIELDING BILLIONS OF DOLLARS OF
DIVIDENDS -- FOR A VERY MODEST
INVESTMENT I THINK IS ONE MORE
PIECE OF THAT PUZZLE SO AND AND
KRISTIN ARE BOTH HERE SO
DIRECTOR THE ARTS COUNCIL AS
WELL AS OUR CHAIR -- THE ARTS
COUNCIL [inaudible]
HI.
WITH THE SEER YEAH -- I WANT TO
THANK YOU ASSEMBLYMAN CHIU FOR
SHARING THIS COMMITTEE AND FOR
BEING THE VICE CHAIR.
OF THE JOINT COMMITTEE OF THE
ARTS YOU REALLY ARE AN ARTS
CHAMPION.
OKAY -- I MAN BOUND CRAWFORD
DIRECTOR OF THE CALIFORNIA ARTS
COUNCIL THANK YOU FOR HEARING US
ABOUT SB SEVEN FORTY EIGHT THE
YOUTH POET LAUREATE BILL.
SOMETHING CLOSE TO OUR HEARTS
WE'RE GRATEFUL TO SENATOR STERN
ALONG WITH SENATORS ALAN AND
HERTZBERG FOR OFFERING THE BILL
OFFERING THE BILL.
THE CALIFORNIA ARTS COUNCIL
SUBMITTED A FORMAL REQUEST TO
THE GOVERNOR'S OFFICE TO BRING
THIS LEGISLATION TO ESTABLISH A
CALIFORNIA.
YOUTH POET LAUREATE.
WHO SHALL BE APPOINTED BY
GOVERNOR NEWS SOME AND CONFIRMED
BY THE SENATE FROM A LIST OF
THREE NOMINEES THAT WE PROVIDE
THROUGH -- A VERY SPECIFIC
PROCESS THAT WE HAVE.
THE CALIFORNIA YOUTH POET
LAUREATE AS A GOVERNOR'S
APPOINTEE WOULD HAVE THE MISSION
TO ADVOCATE FOR THE ART OF
POETRY IN CLASSROOMS AND
COMMUNITIES ACROSS THE STATE.
AND TO INSPIRE AND EMERGING
GENERATION OF LITERARY ARTISTS.
AND TO EDUCATE ALL CALIFORNIANS
ABOUT THE MANY POETS AND AUTHORS.
THAT HAVE INFLUENCED OUR GREAT
STATE THROUGH CREATIVE LITERARY
EXPRESSION.
THIS LEGISLATION WILL TAKE AN
IMPORTANT STEP TOWARDS
RECOGNIZING THAT THE CREATED
VOICES OF OUR YOUTH ARE HEARD.
THAT THEY MATTER.
THAT THEY CAN MAKE A DIFFERENCE
AND THAT THEY HAVE IMPACT I'M
HERE TODAY WITH THE CALIFORNIA
ARTS COUNCIL'S DIRECTOR OF
LEGISLATIVE AFFAIRS.
KRISTIN MARGOLIS WHO CAN TELL
YOU.
A LITTLE BIT ABOUT.
THE BILL IF YOU HAVE ANY
QUESTIONS AT ALL [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU CHAIRMAN STADIUM UGH
GET A MICROPHONE [inaudible]
THANKS.
I WANT TO GET ON THE ITALIAN
INNER CALM HERE AND YOU ALSO.
THANK YOU -- CHAIRMAN TO AND
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE -- IT'S
A PLEASURE TO BE HERE TODAY WE
ARE VERY EXCITED ABOUT THIS BILL --
WE'VE HAD A LOT OF SUCCESS WITH
OUR ADULT POET LAUREATE PROGRAM
REACHING OUT TO ALL COMMUNITIES
THROUGHOUT CALIFORNIA.
AND AND SO IT'SREALLY -- THAT
EXAMPLE PLUS OUR POETRY OUT LOUD
PROGRAM WHERE WE SERVE TENS OF
THOUSANDS OF HIGH SCHOOL
STUDENTS THROUGHOUT CALIFORNIA.
THEY GAVE US THIS IDEA OF HAVING
A YOUTH POET LAUREATE -- WE ALSO
FEEL THAT IT -- NOT ONLY IS THE
INTEREST GREAT BUT ALSO THE IDEA
OF GIVING USE THAT YOUNG ADULTS
STATEWIDE AN OPPORTUNITY TO
PARTICIPATE IN PUBLIC SERVICE --
IS IS A WONDERFUL THING -- WE
KNOW THAT POETRY IS A WAY OF
TELLING STORIES AND BRINGING
PEOPLE TOGETHER.
AND BAD WRITING POETRY IS
CERTAINLY A WAY F ADVANCING
STUDENTS VOCABULARY AND INTEREST
IN THE LITERARY ARTS -- SO WE
URGE THAT YOU SUPPORT THIS BILL
HERE TODAY -- I ALSO JUST LIKE
TO ADD THERE'S A BILL THAT CAN
BE HEARD AFTER THIS AND THE
CREATIVE ECONOMY IS SOMETHING
THAT THE CALIFORNIA ARTS
COUNCILS.
BEEN INVOLVED IN FOR MANY YEARS --
PRODUCING REPORTS WITH THE OTIS
COLLEGE OF ART AND DESIGN AND WE
ARE VERY INTERESTED IN THAT BILL
AS WELL AND AND POSSIBLY --
JOINING ON TO BE PART OF THAT
TASK FORCE AND THEN ONE FINAL
THING I JUST WANTED TO MENTION
IS THAT IN THE ANALYSIS -- THE
DEAN OF THE CONSULTANT PROVIDED
SHE MENTIONED A HERTZBERG BILL
WHICH IS SENATE BILL -- TWO
THIRTY SEVEN AND THAT BILL IS --
REFER TO AS A STEM BILL AND WE
ARE HOPEFUL THAT THIS COMMITTEE
WILL CONSIDER MAKING THAT INTO A
STEAM BELL ADDING THE ARTS --
AND AS IT GOES THROUGH THE
ASSEMBLY.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH IS THERE ANY --
ADDITIONAL -- WITNESSES TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT -- FOR SB
SEVEN FORTY EIGHT PLEASE COME.
FOR GOOD MORNING I'M JULIE BAKER
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF CALIFORNIA
ARTS ADVOCATES AND WE'RE HERE TO
REGISTER OUR SUPPORT FOR THE
BILL.
THIS IS DEFINITELY SOMETHING THE
FIELD WOULD LOVE TO SEE HAPPEN.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH ANY
OPPOSITION.
SEEING NONE ANY COMMENTS FROM.
COLLEAGUES IN THE COMMITTEE.
TALK TO CHOI.
DID YOU BRING UP POOR AT THE FOR
THIS MEETING.
I WISH WE DID WE TRY TO YEAH BUT
YOU KNOW SCHOOL JUST LET OUT.
I HEARD YOU RIGHT OUT OF RIGHT
NOW I CAN GO TO GOING TO IMPROVE.
I'M HERE PROBABLY.
OKAY THEN.
WE'LL GIVE YOU A CHANCE TO TO
RESET YOUR POETRY [inaudible]
YES [inaudible]
SO.
THE POEM IS BOY WITH BROKEN
WINDOW LIKE WHEN DILLON BROOKS.
I SHALL CREATE.
IF NOT A NOTE THE WHOLE.
IF NOT AN OVERTURE A DESECRATION.
WE HAVE A CHANCE TO BUILD AN
OVERTURE.
I'D RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR
AYE VOTE [inaudible]
VERY CREATIVE.
OKAY YOU GET MEADOW YOU GOT MY
VOTE.
ALL RIGHT ASSEMBLYMEMBER
FRIEDMAN WERE UP ON THE SB SOME
OF FORTY EIGHT THE ALSO JUST
PRESENTED.
THE VEIL DO YOU HAVE ANY
QUESTIONS.
CONCERNED COMMENT [inaudible]
ALL RIGHT [inaudible]
THE MOTION.
THANK YOU SO TO HAVE A MOTION TO
HAVE A CAR.
OKAY BUT BEFORE WE TAKE A VOTE
ON THIS I WANT TO FIRST
ESTABLISH OF CORN SO.
CIRCULAR ROOM WOULD YOU PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL.
KANSEN CHU.
HERE.
HE DAVID CHAIR.
CHOI HERE CHOI HERE FRIEDMAN.
FRIEDMAN HERE COM WATER DOES.
IN THIS AREA.
THIS HEARING HERE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH NO WOOD TO
HOW I MAKE A MOTION BUT JUST
WANTED -- TO AGAIN THE OF THANK
THANK SENATOR STROM WILL BRING
THIS.
BILL TO US AND ALSO FOR YOUR
CONTINUOUS EFFORT IN.
IN HIS -- ARCH AND AND
ENTERTAINMENT BUT NO OR STAY AND
SLOW S. VIA OUR OUR CONSUL YOU
KNOW.
HOW THEY HONOR TO WORKING WITH
YOU FOR MANY YEARS?
AND YOU GUYS ARE REALLY A GOOD
LOOK AT CHAMPION. TO TO TO THE
ARTS AND AND MANY OF THE CULTURE
EVENT.
IN OUR STATE SO -- WHAT WAS SO
BEAUTIFUL POINT?
FROM US SENATORS STORM I JUST.
I DO HAVE A AYE RECOMMENDATION.
AND I WOULD LIKE TO ASK THE
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
[inaudible]
THESE ARE -- OKAY WILL STE.
IS STILL -- WALA ENTERTAINED A
SECOND [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
SO THE BILL IS THE SEC.
DOCTOR CHOI AND SECOND BY.
ASSEMBLYMEMBER FRIEDMAN.
SB SEVEN FORTY EIGHT STERN TO
PASSED TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS.
KANSEN CHU BY KANSEN CHU <c.cyan>WI</c>
THE DAVID CHIU.
CHOI HI CHOI I FRIEDMAN.
I COME LONGER DATA [inaudible]
THIS AREA.%
HI NAZARIAN NOT REGULAR THANK
YOU WILL LEAVE A ROLL HOPING
PEOPLE TO ABSENT.
MEMBERS [inaudible]
AND ALSO WON'T GO BACK TO THE
CONSENT CALENDAR WILL HAVE ONE
NIGHT.
TO AJ ARE.
FOURTEEN I MAKE A MOTION.
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
KANSEN CHU HI KANSEN CHU I THINK.
DAVID CHIU YOU.
CHOI HI CHOI I FRIEDMAN.
I COME LONGER TO HAVE.
RIGHT THANK YOU -- THE LAST ITEM
WE HAVE HERE.
IS FUNDS I SENATOR AMBERG ON SB
SERMON.
THIRTY SIX SENATOR.
FLOWCHARTS THANK YOU -- MISTER
CHAIR AND MEMBERS AND NOT TO BE
OUTSHONE BY SENATOR STERN.
SO ROSES ARE RED VIOLETS ARE
BLUE I AM PLEASED TO PRESENT
FILE ITEM NUMBER -- TWO
AUTOMATIC THE THAT WAS YOUR YEAH
RIGHT.
NO AUTOMATICALLY ENJOY THE AYE
RECOMMENDATION BY THE CHAIR.
ALL RIGHT.
THANK YOU -- REMOVE THE BILL
GOOD FOR YOU ALL RIGHT SO -- I I
AM PLEASED PRESENT SENATE BILL
SEVEN THIRTY SIX CONCERNING THE
CREATIVE ECONOMY -- AS I THINK
YOU KNOW -- CALIFORNIA.
BEING THE LARGEST STATE.
AND BEING ABLE TO THRIVE BY
VIRTUE OF BY BY VIRTUE OF SO
MANY.
ENTITIES THAT WANT TO COME TO
OUR FAIR LAND OF FOR PURPOSES OF
ALL SORTS OF ENTERTAINMENT
ACTIVITIES CULTURAL ACTIVITIES --
BUT WE DO COMPETE WITH OTHER
STATES WE DO COMPETE WITH OTHER
STATES -- IN AREAS OF FOR
EXAMPLE MUSICAL CONCERTS
FESTIVALS RODEOS ALL SORTS OF
THINGS AND THE PURPOSE OF THIS
BILL IS TO CREATE A TASK FORCE.
TO STUDY -- RECOMMENDATIONS AS
TO HOW WE CAN BE MORE
COMPETITIVE WITH OTHER STATES.
OF THE TASK FORCE LEASES I
ENVISION IT WILL MAKE CERTAIN
RECOMMENDATIONS AS TO HOW WE CAN
COMPETE.
AND LIVER A REPORT TO ALL OF US
HERE IN THE LEGISLATURE -- WITH
ME HERE ARE SEVERAL FOLKS TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT -- AND I
WOULD URGE AN AYE VOTE.
SO I JUST CRIED RIGHT.
I CAN GO AHEAD GOOD MORNING MY
NAME IS PATTY MAKE JANET I'M
WITH LOS ANGELES -- TO RESUME
AND CONVENTION BOARD -- AND WE
ARE HERE -- TO GAIN COURAGE YOU.
TO MOVE THIS BILL FOR WORK -- WE
BELIEVE THAT IT IS QUITE
NECESSARY BECAUSE CITIES AND
STATES ACROSS THE COUNTRY HAVE
REALLY COME TO UNDERSTAND THE
SIGNIFICANT ECONOMIC IMPACTS OF
THESE EVENTS AND IT'S GOT TO BE
VERY VERY COMPETITIVE PROCESS.
AND SO NOT JUST LARGEST NATIONS
LIKE OURSELVES BUT SMALLER
DESTINATIONS WITHIN THE STATE
REALLY DO NEED ASSISTANCE IN
TRYING TO ATTRACT THESE FUNDS
HAVE BEEN THAT WE WILL CONTINUE.
TO FUND RAISE IT WILL CONTINUE
TO WORK WITH OUR HOST COMMITTEE
SIX CENTER BUT THE INCENTIVE --
TO THE FINANCIAL ASSISTANCE TO
MOVE IT FORWARD IT WILL REALLY
BE APPRECIATED AND IT'S NOT A
NEW CONCEPT OF THE STATE OF
TEXAS FOR INSTANCE FLORIDA --
HAVE BEEN VERY SUCCESSFUL TEXAS
IN PARTICULAR -- WITHIN THE LAST
TEN YEARS THE FACT OF LIKE THREE
HUNDRED AND FIFTY EVENTS TO
THEIR AREA.
SO -- THE YOU'LL SEE FLORIDA THE
ATLANTA OTHER CITIES STARTING TO
REPLICATE THAT AS WELL.
AND SO -- THE LAST THING I JUST
WANT TO SAY IS THAT WE ARE
FEELING -- VERY SUPPORTED BY THE
OTHER TOURISM OFFICE TO
CALIFORNIA'S YOU SEE BY THE
SUPPORT LETTERS WE'VE GOT NEARLY
FORTY LETTERS THAT CAME IN AGAIN
FROM DESTINATIONS BOTH URBAN AND
RURAL -- SO WE THINK THAT THERE
IS BEING ABOUT THE INDUSTRY
THERE IS VERY MUCH WIDE SUPPORT
FOR THIS PROJECT YOU'RE GREAT.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH AND WOULD
HELP HER PHONE LOS ANGELES THOSE
HERE FROM SAN JOSE.
YEAH GOOD MORNING THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR AND MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE MY NAME IS CAROLYN
KERR KESSLER AND I'M THE CEO
VISITS AND I WAS A TEAM SAN JOSE.
WE ARE THE OFFICIAL DESTINATION
MARKETING ORGANIZATION AND WE
ALSO MANAGED TO SAN JOSE MCENERY
CONVENTION CENTER ALONG WITH
FOUR THEATERS.
IN THE PAST FOUR YEARS SAN JOSE
IS HOSTED FOR MAJOR SPORTING
EVENTS THAT REQUIRED A
SIGNIFICANT LOCAL INVESTMENT.
IN TWO THOUSAND FIFTEEN WE
PARTNERED WITH LEVI STADIUM IN
SANTA CLARA TO HOST WRESTLEMANIA
THIRTY ONE THIS EVEN COST OUR
ORGANIZATION AND THE SPORTS
AUTHORITY A TOTAL OF ALMOST ONE
MILLION DOLLARS JUST A HOST THAT
DOESN'T INCLUDE ANYTHING THAT.
SANTA CLARA MIGHT HAVE DONE OR
LEVI STADIUM.
IN TWO THOUSAND SIXTEEN ONE
SUPER BOWL FIFTY TOOK PLACE IN
LEVI STADIUM WHICH IS
APPROXIMATELY NINE MILES FROM
OUR DOWNTOWN WE INVESTED ALMOST
TWO POINT TWO MILLION DOLLARS
JUST IN SAN JOSE ALONE.
I IMAGINE THAT SAN FRANCISCO'S
INVESTMENT WAS SIGNIFICANTLY
MORE BECAUSE THAT'S WHERE MANY
OF MUCH OF THE ACTIVATION WAS
DONE.
THAT EVEN BROUGHT ABOUT TWO
HUNDRED AND FIFTY MILLION
DOLLARS TO THE BAY AREA.
EARLIER THIS YEAR WE HOSTED TWO
MAJOR EVENTS JUST WEEKS APART
AND IT WAS A REAL FINANCIAL
STRAIN FOR US THE COLLEGE
FOOTBALL PLAYOFF NATIONAL
CHAMPIONSHIPS REQUIRED AN
OVERALL INVESTMENT OF ALMOST TWO
POINT FOUR MILLION DOLLARS.
A FEW WEEKS LATER THE NHL ALL
STAR GAME TOOK PLACE AND THEY
NEED AN INVESTMENT OF ALMOST A
HALF A MILLION DOLLARS.
WELL SO WITH SOME EVENTS THEIR
BID FEES INVOLVED IN THERE ARE
SOME SMALLER EVENTS THAT OTHER
CITIES COULD HOST FOR INSTANCE
THE US GYMNASTICS CHAMPIONSHIPS
AND CONGRESS -- THIRTEEN TRIALS
THEY REQUIRE A HUNDRED AND FIFTY
THOUSAND DOLLAR BID FOR YOU JUST
TO PUT IN A BAD SO THAT DOESN'T
INCLUDE ALL OF THE OTHER --
COSTS THAT ARE ASSOCIATED WITH
IT WE WOULD LOVE TO BE ABLE TO
BUILD MORE OF THESE BUT HONESTLY
IT'S A REAL FINANCIAL STRAIN SO
WE HAVE -- TO PICK AND CHOOSE
WERE ALWAYS COMPETING WITH OTHER
STATES I DON'T KNOW OF A TIME
WHEN WE'VE ACTUALLY COMPETED
WITH ANYONE ELSE IN THE STATE
BECAUSE WE DO A GOOD JOB OF
SOMEBODY ELSE IS GOING FOR WE
TYPICALLY DON'T -- SO WE WE WANT
THE BUSINESS AND CALIFORNIA I'VE
ONLY GIVEN YOU EXAMPLES OF
SPORTING EVENTS BECAUSE THAT'S
PARTICULARLY WHAT MY
ORGANIZATION HAS BEEN INVOLVED
IN BUT THERE ARE NOT A DOZENS OF
OTHER CULTURAL AGRICULTURAL AND
ENTERTAINMENT EVENTS.
THAT WOULD ALSO BE IMPACTED BY
THIS THESE EVENTS ATTRACT
INTERNATIONAL ATTENTION THEY
PROVIDE REVENUES FOR HOTELS
RESTAURANTS SHOPPING
TRANSPORTATION AND THEY CREATE
AND FOSTER INNOVATION AND
ENCOURAGE SPILLOVER EFFECTS THAT
CREATE OPPORTUNITIES FOR OTHER
INDUSTRIES BY ATTRACTING
INVESTMENT.
TOURISM CONSUMER SPENDING AND BY
GENERATING TAX REVENUE.
SO WE THANK YOU FOR CONSIDERING
THIS BILL -- AND WE RESPECTFULLY
REQUEST TO VOTE IN FAVOR.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH A MILITARY
STRUCTURE AND MEMBERS BOB YOU'RE
ON BEHALF OF THE LOS ANGELES
RAMS ORGANIZATION IN THE LOS
ANGELES CLIPPERS ORGANIZATION.
WOULD LIKE TO THANKS AND
REMEMBERED FOR HIS BILL -- I
THINK I'D JUST ONE ECHO WITH THE
OTHER -- WITNESSES OF SAID BUT I
ALSO WANT TO SAY THAT MOST OF
THESE EVENTS THEIR WEEK LONG
EVENTS THEIR WEEK LONG EVENTS
THAT BRING IN.
A LOT OF REVENUE TO THE LOCAL
ECONOMY AND IT TAKES A LOT OF
WORK ON BEHALF OF THE LOCAL
ORGANIZATIONS THAT SPONSOR THEM.
IT ALSO GENERATES JOBS.
I'M ALSO HERE ON BEHALF OF THE
PAINTERS DISTRICT COUNCIL THIRTY
SIX THAT REPRESENT THE SIGN IN
PICTORIAL DISPLAY UNION WORKERS
THEY DO ALL THE TRADE SHOWS THEY
DO ALL THE LINING IN THE END
ZONE PAINTING. FOR ALL THE
ATHLETIC EVENTS SO THERE ARE
JOBS GENERATED BUT THERE HAS TO
BE MONEY ON THE FRONT END. ONE
OF THE OTHER EVENTS THAT I WOULD
NOTE IS THAT EVERY YEAR THE CITY
OF MODESTO HOSTS THE AMERICAN
GRAFFITI -- CREWS AND THAT HAS
GONE FROM SIX HUNDRED CARS TWO
THREE THOUSAND CARDS THIS YEAR
THAT IS THE LARGEST REVENUE
GENERATOR FOR THE CITY MODESTO
AND HAS BEEN FOR THE LAST TWENTY
YEARS.
SO ON ON MY ORGANIZATIONS BEHALF
WE SUPPORT THE BILL AND THINKS
AND AMBER. THREE THANK YOU VERY
MUCH AT ANY ADDITIONAL WITNESSES
IN SUPPORT PLEASE MORNING FULLER
CALMLY WITH THE LA COUNTY BOARD
OF SUPERVISORS IN STRONG SUPPORT.
THANK YOU.
OUR INNER FOR THE CALIFORNIA
CHAMBER OF COMMERCE IN SUPPORT
THANK YOU.
VANESSA GONZALEZ ON BEHALF OF
THE CALIFORNIA TRAVEL
ASSOCIATION AND SUPPORT THANK
YOU.
JULIE BECKER IN FAVOR OF WITH A
CAT CALIFORNIA ARTS ADVOCATES IN
FAVOR BUT WE WANTED JUST
STIPULATE THAT ALSO.
THAT IN THE TASK FORCE THAT WE
HAVE REPRESENTATION FROM THE
ARTS COMMUNITY IN PARTICULAR
SOMEONE FROM THE CALIFORNIA ARTS
COUNCIL LIKE THEIR EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR.
AS WELL AS OTHER ARTS LEADERS
ACROSS THE STATE.
THANK YOU GRAY THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIRMAN I MOVE THE BILL.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH TO AT THE
SECOND ANY OPPOSITION.
WITNESSES AND OPPOSITION PLEASE
CALL FOR SEEN NONE.
ANY COMMENTS AND QUESTIONS FROM
THE MEMBERS [inaudible]
YES.
THIS REST AREA THE FIRST OF ALL
MISTER CHAIR I THINK IT WAS
ALREADY MOVED AND SECONDED BY
MRS FRIEDMAN AND MYSELF ARE STE
FOR THE RECORD -- SECOND MONTH
SOME OF US WERE IN THE EARLY
KNOW THAT MOVED -- AND GET TO
THE VEHICLE.
NO BUT I I I IN ALL SERIOUSNESS
I WANTED JUST TAKE A MOMENT AND
SAY FOR SO THANK YOU FOR IT THE
REPRESENTATIVES OF OF OF THE TWO
CITIES TOURISM.
GROUPS. TO FOR BEING HERE AND
FOR PRESENTING THIS UP WE HAVE A
LOT OF CHALLENGES IN LA -- WE WE
DON'T EVEN HAVE ENOUGH HOTEL
ROOMS TO SET TO HELP SUPPORT
SOME OF THE EFFORTS.
IN BRINGING SOME OF THESE BIG
ITEM -- CONVENTIONS THAT TO OUR
CITY AND WE SOMETIMES HAVE IT
COMPETED AWAY BY MUCH SMALLER
PLACES.
AND IT'S THIS PROGRAM IS SUCH A
WONDERFUL PROGRAM BECAUSE IT
ALMOST AS LIKE A MICRO LOAN.
SYSTEM OF HELPING INCENTIVIZE
OUR LOCAL JURISDICTIONS -- TO TO
BRING IN PROGRAM PROJECTS INTO
INTO IT INTO THEIR DOMAIN.
AND I JUST WONDER IN TEN YEARS
FROM NOW HOW WE CAN LOOK BACK
AND SAY FOR EVERY DOLLAR SPENT
BY THE STATE -- HOW MUCH THE
CITIES WERE ABLE TO BENEFIT --
AND WITH THAT THE ONLY THING I
WOULD ALSO SAY IS -- I'M SORRY
THAT THE BILL WAS AMENDED -- TO
TO TO TO BE WHAT IT IS NOW BUT
IT'S A STARTING POINT AND SO
WILL HOPEFULLY STRENGTHENING
STRENGTHENED TO WHAT IT -- IT'LL
BECOME EVENTUALLY WHAT THE
INITIAL BILL WAS MEANT TO BE.
SO THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR YOUR
WORK ON THE SENATOR WELL THANK
YOU -- ASSEMBLY MEMBER IN HIS
AREA OF THIS IS A WORK IN
PROGRESS AND AND WE DO EXPECT
THAT.
IT WILL CONTINUE BOMB ALONG THE
LINES AS ORIGINALLY INTENDED.
THANK YOU ASSEMBLY MEMBER CHIU
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR -- I WANT
TO JUST THANK -- THE GOOD
SENATOR FOR YOUR AUTHORSHIP OF
THIS IS YOU AND I'VE DISCUSSED I
REPRESENT -- THE NUMBER ONE
TOURIST DESTINATION IN NORTHERN
CALIFORNIA WHICH IS SAN
FRANCISCO AND WE'VE ACTUALLY
DISCUSSED THIS VERY CONCEPT.
OF OF TRYING TO MOVE FORWARD --
THIS TYPE OF ASSISTANCE TO BRING
IN MORE CREATIVE WAYS OF OF OF
OF VISITORS TO OUR STATE SO.
VERY HAPPY TO SUPPORT TODAY AND
ALSO HAPPY IF IT IF YOU SO
PLEASE TO ADD MYSELF AS A OR B.
ADDED AS A CO AUTHOR HAPPY TO
HELP THE BILL FOR YOU.
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH DOCTOR CHOI.
THANK YOU CHAIR AND A A CENTER
REMEMBER BECAUSE I IT WILL
SUPPORT THE YOU ARE A VERY
CREATIVE IDEA TO HIS TABLETS TO
CREATIVELY CONSUMMATE TASK FORCE.
WITHIN THE ARE.
OF COLBY IS WHICH I UNDERSTAND
IS SO WITHIN THE GOVERNOR'S
OFFICE SO.
ARE LISTENING TO YOUR THE
OVERALL CREATIVE -- ECONOMY
CONCEPT.
IS JUST ABOUT THE ANYTHING.
YOU KNOW IT'S A FROM ARTS --
SPORES SICK COMMA ME EVENTS --
ANYTHING IN OUR THAT IS STILL
GOING ON I'M I'M VERY CURIOUS --
HOW IS THIS A NEW TASK FORCE --
WORRY IMPACT THE EXISTING
COPIOUS STAFF MEMBERS ARE TO BE
MORE CREATIVE -- ARE -- WITH A
INSPIRED A TO DO DIFFERENT
ACTIVITIES SO BY THIS TASK FORCE
SO.
SO THE HOUSE -- JUST A GENERAL
OR QUESTION.
AND THIS -- TERMINOLOGY CREATIVE
ECONOMY WHEN I HEARD -- SEVERAL
YEARS AGO.
IN KOREA A FULL MORE PRESS THAN.
YEAH TWO AND HALF PA I THOUGHT
THAT THE WAS SO HER CREATIVE.
TERMINOLOGY.
AS SHE SAID THAT TIME JOE CAM
JET TRANSLATES EXACTLY AS A
CREATIVE ECONOMY.
BUT NOW HERE THIS ULTIMATE OLOGY
HAS BEEN AROUND.
SO MAYBE YOU CAN ALSO DEFINE.
WHAT THAT IS EXACTLY SECOND
QUESTION WOULD BE WHAT WHAT THAT
DOES SENT THEM WHEN AND WHERE IT
THIS WAS SO ORIGINATED -- IT
DIDN'T SOUND LIKE CUT US SO.
A NEW IDEA.
THAT HAVE ABSOLUTELY.
COME AROUND.
SO IF YOU CAN SHERMAN ON THOSE
CIRCUMVENT LET ME LET ME RESPOND.
ANSWER THE QUESTION WILL BE HOW
THE MOTION AND THE SECOND ON THE
FLOOR AND SET SEVERAL OF THEM
MEMBERS INCLUDING MYSELF HAVE TO
GO. 2% BILLS IN THE IN THE IN
THE SENATE COMMITTEES SO I LIKE
TO JUST A A TAKE A BOAT PERSON
AND THEM YOU CAN I TAKE YOUR
TIME.
ANSWERING THE QUESTION PHONE
DOCTOR CHOI.
SO MADONNA SECONDARY WOULD YOU
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
SB SEVEN THREE SIX NUMBER TWO
PASSED TO THE COMMITTEE ON JOBS
ECONOMIC DEVELOPMENT IN THE
ECONOMY KANSEN CHU YOU ARE
KANSEN CHU ÁI DEEP HI STEVE
I DAVID CHIU HI.
DAVID CHIU AYE CHOI.
CHOI I FRIEDMAN.
COM ORDER DOES.
HOMEWORK OR DEATH I IS THERE IN.
THIS AREA.
OF WITH THE GERMAN.
IS IT OKAY WITH YOU IF --
ASSEMBLYMEMBER EACH GIVES YOU
AND I ALSO ADD ON THE REST OF
THE BILLS AS WELL DEFINITELY --
WHAT WHAT DO THEY AT ALL?
SB. FOUR SEVEN FORTY EIGHT STERN
DEEP HI I DAVID CHIU.
DAVID CHIU I'D OPEN CONSENT.
CONSENT CALENDAR.
DEEP I DEEP I DAVID CHIU DAVID
CHIU I'D.
IN A MENACING WITH IT.
SO -- LET LET ME LET ME LET ME
THANK -- MISS QUICKER CHRYSLER
AND ALSO -- MISS MAC JENNETTE
FOR TRAVELING TO SACRAMENTO IN
IN SUPPORT OF THE IDEA ADD TO
ANSWER YOUR QUESTION A TAX CHOI --
TWO THINGS ONE IT THIS ISN'T
JUST A GOVERNMENT FOLKS FROM
SACRAMENTO THEM INVOLVED THE
TASK FORCE WE DO.
EXPECT -- THAT THIS CREATIVE
ENERGY WILL COME FROM MANY FOLKS
IN CALIFORNIA AND LET ME
UNDERLINE THE PARTICIPATION THE
ARTS COUNCIL AS WAS MENTIONED.
THAT'S A CRITICAL COMPONENT OF
THIS AND MUCH OF THE
CONVERSATIONS BEEN AROUND SPORTS.
SPORTS IMPORTANT WE LIKE SPORTS --
BUT THE OTHER ACTIVITIES WITH
SHAKESPEARE FESTIVAL OR WHETHER
IT'S THE AMERICAN GRAFFITI EVENT
IN FRESNO WHETHER IT'S A RODEO
ALL ALL THOSE THINGS.
ARE.
INCREDIBLY IMPORTANT FOR
CALIFORNIA TO BE COMPETITIVE
WITH OTHER STATES AND THAT'S
PART OF THE PURPOSE.
OF THE SECOND QUESTION IS
WHETHER I THINK IT WAS WHETHER
THIS IS MY ORIGINAL IDEA.
AND I WOULD LOVE TO CLAIM CREDIT
BUT IS NOT MY ORIGINAL IDEA --
MANY FOLKS INCLUDE THE PEOPLE
HERE -- WITH ME TODAY HAVE
CREATED THE IDEA AND I'M MERELY
A VEHICLE.
HISTORY BEHIND IT THEREFORE THE
TERMINOLOGY IDEA CREATED A
CREATIVE ECONOMY TERMINOLOGY I
AM NOT SURE -- RESPECTED THAT
MAY BE ABLE TO RESPOND AYE I
DON'T KNOW -- BUT THE CREATIVE
ECONOMY IS IS DE TERMINOLOGY
THAT SHE USED TO TALK ABOUT THE
CREATIVE INDUSTRIES AND THEY CAN
BE EVERYTHING FROM DESIGN TO
ARTS.
TO CULINARY TO ANY OF THOSE
INDUSTRIES WHERE YOU ARE
CREATING -- AND THERE'S A WHOLE
REPORT THAT YOU MIGHT FIND
REALLY INTERESTING AND THIS DONE
BY OTIS -- AND IT'S ALL ON THE
CREATIVE ECONOMY AND THOUSAND
NINETEEN REPORT JUST CAME OUT SO
IF WE CAN WE CAN SHARE THAT.
WITH YOU I THINK YOU FIND IT
REALLY INTERESTING.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH AND AND WITH.
RIGHTLY SAID CREATIVE -- ECONOMY
AND A VERY CREATIVE TURN OUT OF
A MEETING WILL CUT WILL BRING
THIS MEETING.
TO AND IF THERE'S NO OTHER
QUESTIONS.
WE'RE ADDING ON THE PLEASE DO.
AND CAN THANK CALENDAR COME
LONGER DEAF.
I WONDERED IF I SB SEVEN FORTY
EIGHT STERN COME LONGER TO HAVE.
FUN MARKETS HAVE.
AGAIN THANK YOU VERY MUCH CENTER
I'M BURKE AND AS WELL AS THE
REPRESENTATIVES FROM LOS ANGELES
AND SAN JOSE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY.
GOOD [inaudible]
EXCEPT THIS